could you could be a politician Andrew
you totally could I have no interest in
doing it why
it's it's you're just a pawn for these
billion dollar corporations but what if
you're a billionaire like Trump and
you're not upon that's the craziest
thing about Trump is that he's wealthy
and still wants to do it that's
ridiculous that's [__] insane it's
ridiculous or this is gonna sound crazy
it's gonna get clipped on the bar I
don't give a [__]
it's crazy or
he's somebody who's going ugh this is
going to [__] he's either oh I need
power I have all the money in the world
money's boring I want power so he's just
going to get the power or I have all the
money in the world I have all the power
in the world because I tell these
politicians what to do anyway and I
genuinely think the wrong people are in
charge and I'll do something about it
because there's no reason you would have
all the money yeah that's so Noble
that's so Noble why the [__] would you
do that most likely the first one
being in that position has got to be the
most horrible thing on the planet that's
horrible so here's the question you got
all the fame that you've ever wanted
right me yeah there's no more Fame you
could get you could
you could comes out and then nobody
talks about them six months later so it
just goes up and down you felt the top
right yeah I'm not trying to fluff I'm
just saying that you felt it right
is it let's say you go okay I felt the
top
is is are you motivated by money now
because you're like all right I already
got all the fame and I'm kind of it
doesn't make me feel any different let
me see if all the money in the world
makes me different no no I I at one
point I was motivated by goals goals
really but had those goals shifted to
financial ones no I just want to be
happy and do what I love which is
um I I guess the answer would always
just
come back to entertain
and create and create like create is
very important because the bar for
entertaining is getting very low which
is why I'm good at what I do
see this is the thing that like and
that's why I I sometimes I'll reference
the 99 Originals thing like I was like
oh he's making art
this is Art when I fall back fully from
social media which will happen and I
know longer subject my life
to the commentary of strangers because
that's a weird phenomenon that like any
person in the Limelight
who understands like that's just so like
everyone just can say whatever they want
about your life it's it's it's wild but
it's what we sign up for sure okay I'm
here now I'm gonna do it but when I fall
back finally I'm gonna I'm gonna do R
I'm gonna do art I don't think as Logan
Paul I'm just gonna [__] make art and
the 99 Originals bizarre thanks bro I
love that project and I'll be 50 50 put
me on to that I'll be back I'll be doing
more bro like I really love that [__] it
was these tiny little stories that were
great they're delicious they're
nutritious and by nutritious I mean like
you could really clearly see that there
is like a story in there but also art
and
I'm not against doing things for
mainstream consumption because I think
that's great but I think that right now
what you're seeing especially with like
streaming culture is it is so
unbelievably entertaining but the only
way to entertain every second of the day
is to create a car crash and now there's
no art whatsoever and that's the problem
and I consume it I looked I was watching
this guy fousey right who I remember
like back in your generation of
YouTubers he was there and he comes back
now and he's like all over my Instagram
or Tick Tock algorithm and I'm watching
it I'm going this is the most
entertaining thing I've ever seen when
he's around other people that stream
none of them talk because they know that
there's one person that is going to get
all the gravity
but at the same time it's car crash
every single time there's not enough art
and that is what you have to do when you
have to entertain 12 hours in a row you
cannot create art because art requires
reflection it requires thought it
requires passion and love
a car crash doesn't so it's how do I
create a car crash every single moment
and my concern is that there are people
who started their careers with real art
and they were beautiful creators that
now are part of the streaming economy
and have gone to an addiction of
attention and it completely disregarded
their artistic side which they [__]
had and they were like beautiful
creators
beautiful creators and now they're just
like okay this is the latest guy who's
hot I'll be involved in the car crash
with him this is the latest guy who's
hot I'll be involved with a car crash
with him
I guess the reason why I want to talk to
you about that specifically is that
I don't think that you've devolved to
the car crash and I hope you don't
because I've seen what you did with the
99 Originals it maybe wasn't your most
popular thing but it was your most
beautiful thing thanks
so don't do the car and what do you and
what do you feel about it I feel my life
is a car crash
but boxing is Art uh uh no it's it's a
boxing requires skill requires time
requires patience it's not it's not just
boxing you know like uh I think I think
you're right first off we were talking
about this on the way over here like we
are in a dark time what is happening
it's a sign of the times it's what does
that mean
I think in the age of media everything
is so oversaturated now humans are wired
to be attracted to and pay attention to
negativity for some reason more than
positivity we like biological responses
we like seeing things get [__] up yeah
we like seeing things collapse it's
weird to be like you ever be with
someone in the morning who's like dude
how [__] are you bro good morning man
let's shut the [__] up shoot that
positivity and being too much all being
about it uh
um
transpiring it is is rare like humans
humans don't aren't I think wired that
way maybe I don't know there's a [__]
there's a um a philosopher they say that
we're drawn to the negativity because it
was a biological response to keep us
safe right it's like if you think that
there's a snake over there and you hear
some ruffling I have to pay attention to
that because that can save my life
so now it's like if anything is
potentially dangerous we have this
hardwired response yeah to pay attention
to it because it could potentially save
our life now we're watching through
things through screens but it's playing
off of biological impulses from Millions
totally totally they used to make money
murder in the neighborhood find out more
in two hours it's like what I gotta wait
two hours
like mainstream news like the news that
your parents still watching it's all
just [__] killing smarter shooting
robbery
they're all grumpy because that's all I
want because
the neighbor is going to [__] well yeah
every time you turn on the TV it looks
like the neighbor is going also San
Antonio is not the neighborhood you know
what I mean what happens over there yeah
yeah and also like I think we're drawn
to the thing that we have least so most
people have a general
positive day I see so if everybody's
just posting about their day it's like
just all positive boring [__] yeah but
it's like you have once somebody
actually is like hey I'm creating chaos
and I'm posting that it's going it's so
much news in Canada no they're like
the Penguins in the
insane is like what the [__] that [__]
sucks
our news is lit again that's why they're
so nice there's a murderer yeah
they gotta find them of course you're
gonna watch that I think that's why
other countries are obsessed with our
news our politics they know what the
[__] is going on here because it's lit
but I was looking at the bro I'm
watching the the fousey guy and I'm like
holy [__] this is arguably one of the
most entertaining individuals I've ever
seen while at the same time I was like
imagine this guy funneled this level of
entertainment into an art like what
would that become well and it'd be less
profitable it'd be less profitable but I
think that you would have salvation in
it because at the end of the day you'd
go oh wow I'm really proud of what I've
put out
despite people enjoying it and then when
people enjoy it it's the icing on the
cake like I imagine you tell me if I'm
wrong when somebody talked to you about
the 99 originals and was like yo that
shows does that feel better than a
uh Vlog that you put a hundred percent
because you're proud
heart soul creation from my being like
that that project my most proud project
in my life like Kevin it's your art
Kevin my videographer slash little bro
slash roommate shot the whole project
beautifully those whole 99 days he's
like dude I watched the trailer the
other day and I started crying like that
whole journey was so transformative and
like we're in advance your art and lean
into it yeah get addicted to that once
you have the money to be addicted to
your art lean into that if you have
money and you're still addicted to the
attention your life is going to be
miserable 100 guaranteed but it's a lead
it's a leave and that's scary for a lot
of people maybe like like that car crash
bro you know how easy it is to get in
your car and run into a [__] wall
versus sitting down brainstorming trying
to come up with all these ideas actually
executing them to Perfection taking the
time to do it like it's just
it's not as it's not as uh within the
boxing because you access earlier like
why get back into the boxing because
that's just but I see boxing is an art
but what they're doing no offense it's
not like hey we are Elite boxers we're
just like Hey where's your Instagram
[__] are fighting that's a car crash
no [__] what I've seen Jake go from
from he's why you say Jake no I'm being
dead ass like when I saw him go from
from his first fight to what he's doing
now phenomenal it's phenomenal so I'm
like wow this guy's taking the art
seriously yeah yeah and it's like it's a
beautiful thing to [__] see somebody
put that type of dedication into their
craft yeah so I don't look at it as car
crash even what I've seen with um
even when I've seen with the uh some of
the uh the [__] give me some
buzzwords or something no not even
buzzwords
UFC fighter UFC fighter
no not Sean but shout out to [__]
Sean yeah
unfucking believable the best
it's going to come to me but my point is
my point is seeing somebody dedicate
themselves to a craft in an art is a
beautiful thing and especially when you
see the execution of that craft I love
that I agree we are drawn to a fight
because we're human beings and if
there's a fight anywhere we're gonna
watch it but at least if there's craft
there yes but every single fighter we
speak to they look at it like hey I'm in
it for this period of time and I'm
looking at my point where I get out of
it but because there's a cost of
fighting yeah so the cost is the highest
so why take that cost like why oh good
question yeah why you put yourself up to
that club I think it's because I am
doing what I love I'd love to entertain
I love the idea of being a modern day
Gladiator that's so [__] cool to me
dude because I'm capable of it too right
I got this Frame I got a a good uh like
base of Athletics to like you know do
this thing at least a little little bit
at least a little bit enter the
Showmanship enter the entertainment the
build up the feeling of winning and
accomplishing a goal like it's all it's
all there which is why I'll sit here and
say like I don't want to be a full-time
professional boxer I don't have these
dreams of becoming the best boxer in the
world because of the cost I'm not here
forever if I have an opportunity to put
out a couple big fights and entertain
people challenge myself which is half of
the you know like I'm not afraid of
looking failure in the face I'm just not
I've done it 100 times and like when I'm
at those lows or highs is when I learned
the most about myself and then can take
that and become the best person I can